the lady's a former champ so she knows
how to get this done in these
tournaments
sabina welcome congratulations for your
win tell us about this game what do you
think the critical point was when she
went wrong thank you maurice um
it feels good i was actually really
worried that might not be winning the
bishop end game because
i'm not sure i hope it is winning
but um it's it's a nice um
zukswan kind of idea so earlier in the
game i really didn't
i don't know it seemed like she was
really prepared i thought i will trick
her a little bit with some move order
but she was very well prepared
and then i got into a position um you
know after i played a4 in the opening
okay um
i know a few right
like tell me which moments
i don't remember
i mean i think it's got to be before
this before yeah yeah so like i had this
a4 pawn structure and i wasn't sure
because i i made all these weaknesses in
a way so i don't know if 95 was so good
um
i feel like it was good i wanted to play
bishop e1 and f4 and kind of play things
similar to i think bobby fischer came
with this idea of bishop e1 so i was
pretty happy with with the position i
think i was okay with raw but okay i
have some bad pawn structure probably
probably she must have made a mistake
when she took here probably in my
opinion but i don't know i mean engine
might or you might think differently i'm
not sure if taking the knight was a good
idea for her because
the pawn in a4 is weak indeed but you're
not i mean if you go take the pawn in a4
then
your king may not be so safe
i felt my choice of playing f5 a couple
of here actually i
injured
approved but like the position looks so
badly in in a positional
point of view because i have so many
weaknesses so dominate all the dark
squares of those that's true yeah
so
shades of bobbinic but winnick had these
bad structures that became beautiful
structures because he dominated i mean
in the end they had a gorgeous one
it flowered beautifully as i was playing
i wasn't sure how
to evaluate the position i thought it
was okay but i don't know maybe here's
the 96 could have played knight a4
uh sorry here maybe knight a4 tickling
the pawn on c3 because i've
yes
so i'm not sure if i can play c4 then
maybe she has night
night b2 or something like or knight c3
maybe not
i was all we were both getting low on
time at this point so
i mean maybe i'm missing some tactics we
we we just absolutely were smitten
by your move
queen b1 right yeah i love that
we were like wow
we were like this was really good and
then we almost wanted to go all the way
back with yeah
actually this move reminded me i think
it was played by lanier dominguez in uh
in the sink field cup yes the queen
queen one move that kind of idea
because
now her bishop is just completely dead
and then like you want a piece almost
exactly yeah and she she could have
played bishop d5 but then i have c4 d5
and yes right that was the other
alternative that i mean we were just
like
thinking oh my goodness i mean they just
roll talk about pushing baby yeah it was
just really wonderful
but after you did get this position we
were shocked
that you that somehow she fought her way
yeah
because i probably right it's like
black can't move her bishop this is
killing because there's bishop e7 right
and that's an easy win so we were
thinking that blackness basically has no
moves and then you're d5 so we thought
king h1 was your tech prophylaxis
against the only tech
challenge but then you went for this
ending and you were pressure i took at
first i thought it's winning really fast
and then after i took i was like
okay am i still winning this bishop end
game or not because she has some
fortress ideas but now you started to
worry yes
like what i know i can't do anything
anymore so if it's a draw it's a draw
like you can't i don't know
i don't think she has that fortunately
it's winning no it is winning
treasure pawns and the weaknesses well
if she had made it with the king in d7
probably it would be i think it would be
yeah if she could buy one but she has to
waste time making those pawn moves if
she could get this position it's a
totally different game but the problem
is any g6 you would have played your
kingdom yeah
what you have done in the game and that
she did spend some time um after i
played i think king d4 she was
she spent a little bit of time
uh
one move before this
yes she spent some time here after king
d4 i think she was considering both
bishop d6 and king uh
she there but
here we considered king takes c4 i yes
but there's cheese
yes there's check first right yes we but
we were afraid that
for that that this ending could also be
a win for you uh that
it's really crazy but
it's like
you're
three
oh i don't think we were we weren't
blunt
we weren't blundering the g
but we were thinking that even this
ha there could be a zucchuang for black
is it crazy but why why would they risk
it of course not of course yeah that
would be crazy yeah
commentators say all kinds of nonsense
by the way
commentators when we blunder pieces
we get to take our move back but you had
it you had it under control it was
fantastic this all worked out
wonderfully for you and there was
nothing that you could do you yeah you
were winning at
it throughout
them yeah well done thank you well done
wow wow
i mean